je pense le public du pantalon féminin
croit-il encore que l'habit fait le
moine et que certains métiers de femmes
sans que pour autant elle ne soit
inscrite au mlf soit à ce point
incompatible avec le port du pantalon
vous allez en juger et d'abord à un
sondage express deviner dans ces
demoiselles sont en un pantalon de
pantalons trois pantalons jupes une jupe
les statisticiens nommerait cette
séquence un échantillon est bien cet
échantillon permettez-moi pourrait
démontrer que huit femmes sur dix
préfèrent le pantalon
[Musique]
à
vous êtes pour ou contre le pantalon
chez la femme
et dans l'administration aussi dans la
fonction publique oui
les avocats ont
je lui souhaite
pourquoi
c'est pas vraiment pour tous les goûts
ouais j'aurais à prononcer le sermon
personnes ne mangent qu'une farce et
plus jeudi en wii 2 francs complet mais
si on veut c'est pas mal vous êtes pour
le pantalon chez les femmes nous conte
rencontres amoureuses garde chez la
femme tout femme qu'est ce que vous
pensez des femmes qui portent le
pantalon avant de prononcer nous dirige
a rien fait comme il veut
avec les échos
a qu'à voir nos moutons benepe le
domaine pénal parce que le pantalon
effrayant pour les femmes ah oui aubin
la ville de paris à peut-être pas les
crédits nécessaires alors la vie d'un
écrivain pour ou contre le pantalon
contre le pantalon pourquoi parce que le
pantalon c'est une chose d'à mais c'est
une chose bien ennuyeuse déjà là
pourquoi est ce que des femmes devraient
nous révéler maintenant les petites
marques de leurs sous vêtements
ce que nous ne faisons pas nous ça je
trouve ça bien triste et bien pénible
que sous prétexte de libération féminine
elle se met à emprunter nos vêtements
bien ennuyeux va très très bien
[Musique]
c'est après jeanne d'arc bien sûr cette
dame qui porta le pantalon pour la
première fois dans les salons parisiens
george sand puis il fallut attendre
l'ère des garçonnes avant guerre qui
allait lancer la mode après guerre du
pantalon sans doute cette dame georges
au singulier rivalisent attelle avec
celle ci madame calamity jane héroïne du
far west et immortalisé aujourd'hui par
les exploits du sieur lucky luke
l'incorruptible pardon monsieur
pensez vous que les frappes doivent
prendre en talons ou doit-on leur
interdire le pantalon ne passe pas
[Musique]
de paris
tu es
[Musique]
la femme doit elle portait un uniforme
de fonction un pantalon surgir entre
avocats ça se voit mais si vous arrivez
un jour dans un prétoire avec un bermuda
fleurs en dessous de tout si c'est un
bermuda fleurs qui sera caché par la
robe qui arrive toute l'ovalie mollet
donc le brésil on ne verra rien
quoi qu'on en dira ce sont les femmes
qui font la mode ce sont elles qui ont
imposé le pantalon à tel point que 12
millions 500 mille pantalon ont été
vendus en 1972 en france ce qui signifie
compte tenu de l'usure que chaque
française devrait avoir dans sa garde
robe deux ou trois tantale et la
production monte en flèche à tel point
que c'est pratiquement la mort de la
mini j c'est aussi modeste la mini jeux
parce que vous savez la minijupe
monsieur sur chanoine la position du
clergé en matière de jeux chez la femme
est moins sévère sans doute que certains
magistrats non je pense en effet que ce
que nous avons entendu de la part de
certains magistrats a certainement fait
sourire
d'autre part je pense que dans l'église
nous n'avons pas eu à ce sujet là à
prendre des positions qu'ils soient
particulièrement
je ne dis pas regrettable tout au moins
insolite
[Musique]